guys i have some fantastic news it looks
like spider-man away home will be coming
to hbo max but there's a really big
reason why you might not see it
do me a favor first please subscribe and
turn on notifications i am doing this
every day let's get started
according to deadline it looks like sony
picture television and warner media have
extended their current content deal
which will result in recent big-name
pictures like spider-man no way home and
ghostbusters afterlife being made
available on hbo max and hbo channels in
territories across central eastern
europe these regions include poland
czech republic slovakia hungary romania
bulgaria moldova slovenia croatia serbia
montenegro bosnia and north macedonia
other big marvel pictures such as venom
let there be carnage and morbius are
included in this agreement no release
date was given but this will be likely
in the pay one window for norway home
which refers to the first executive
release window on other platforms after
a film's release so unfortunately if you
are in the us you do have to wait to
watch it on any other platform for now
it looks like it will be released solely
on stars streaming platform
again if you haven't already do me a
favor please hit subscribe turn on
notifications i am doing this every day
i'm bringing you those mcu
news updates rumors theories reviews
it's gonna be a fun journey here i am
just getting started so stick around and
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]